here we go five standard
here we go
what do we got okay let's roll with D
for for the win and now what hmm
Knight f3 and now what okay um actually
we've been here before we've played one
other game and so far so much the same
here we played one five minute and it
was in the five minute fanatics for a
second I was thinking about b4 let's not
do that
now what Bishop b2 if you didn't know I
was planning Bishop b2 you should know
that I'm planning it right here um I
think I should challenge that night
right away or should I know I'm gonna do
this and maybe next do this is that
gonna work out let's see Knight here
could take no not really
actually I think you know what I'm
needing to do is something like this
I think if I played knight c6 there's um
like Bishop to be a bishop to f5 and if
I capture the Bishop recaptures and then
it's uncomfortable because I'm still in
a pin and there's timely Bishop takes
Knight moves and then I'm you know I
don't have enough support for this pawn
so right now I'm ready to either push or
capture the dark scribe bishops are
close to being off the board and I
really want to make sure I challenge
this night soon so let's see how I can
make that happen I do have to be
cautious now because maybe the bishop is
going to move and then the rook is going
to play to c8 so now we're going to have
some structural change are we now
I don't know if this is the right thing
to do because I think I could access
this pond or this d5 square
pretty soon we're gonna see about that
though I think look here or maybe Knight
d2 rook here seems like a good idea I'm
gonna try that rook here and then Knight
d2 let me try and get rid of this Knight
and then my idea is that I want to be
able to get to d5 with tempo on the
Queen an additional feature with this is
that I want to maybe get my Bishop out
here but I think we're gonna be seeing
e4 in fact it might turn out to be a
necessity we're gonna see about that
there's still potential one way to view
this is that there is still potential
for what there's still potential I'm
gonna take a picture with my rook
because I want my knight to get to this
Square still potential for a structural
change I don't want to touch this move I
don't want to move this pawn that
Knights gonna land there here or here
hmm I'm gonna go with this and in fact I
think I have I'm gonna go with the
connected past pawn I think that could
be really strong actually if I obtained
the bishop pair then I just have to be
cautious that this night does not do
what that this Knight and I think we're
gonna be having bishop takes I don't
know they could deal tonight I just want
to be sure if I have the bishop here
that this Knight doesn't find a good
home fortunately there is no Knight d4
available so if take stakes I always
have this I don't know that if there's a
way that the knight could access this
square then so I don't okay first I
think just recapture like this and then
after efore that's a pretty slick move
so I can't take the night or can i hmm I
don't want to do this just to support
the pond I think just coming back home
is a good idea let's gonna do that
there's no rush now I'm threatening to
take the night so I'll do this next and
then maybe something like f4 might we
see this the Knights getting ready to
blockade so let me make sure the the the
knight is taken out before it gets to d6
and I'm working on a good versus bad
Bishop position and also having
connected passed pawns so looking to
simplify the position I'm recognizing
that a knight on d6 is going to be quite
strong as an excellent block hater of
the past pawn what's the one line by
tirage a passed pawn must be blockaded
or you know I treat it as if it's a
criminal maybe this is a good idea I'm
gonna try this actually and main point
here I want to stay on this diagonal I
think it's got to be very uncomfortable
and let's back up so now if there's ever
a capture I have this bishop check move
as well you have to be aware that this
bishop could maybe be activated in this
manner along this diagonal and so maybe
I could actually play here I want to try
that or maybe not I'm gonna do this not
quite sure why actually I'd like to
induce this move and then I can retreat
my Queen and then I have to worry about
this bishop move as much I guess I'm
also getting ready to win upon okay
let's come back here now so I don't know
what exactly I accomplished but I
thought it was a slight improvement she
was just trying to get developed so I
have a little bit of a time edge 83
before or maybe just rip to c1 or
something maybe Queen Queen here could
be
an idea let's do this first most I
almost just kind of mouse slipped
they're looking to double and also just
this as well actually have a ton of
Lights grab control it's not by chance
when my hat the bishop I have as the
advantage like the unopposed bish of my
light square bishop is well let's go
what's going on with that all the pieces
are really trying to get off of the
light squares
I think Bishop here is a good idea right
now or actually I'm on this so this is
pretty uncomfortable in fact I think I'm
winning material now okay I'm on the
rook but they're on my clean so now then
whenever pawns make captures files
change so what's the new file that has
been opened up it's this one over here
actually I give a check I think I want
to do that no no no no no no no no I
don't want to do that do you know why
does anybody know why I wouldn't want to
play my bishop there just yet it's
because the knight could eventually
pivot on this square and in fact it
could pivot there right now uh-oh
they're gonna figure out it in time my
Queens unprotected oh that was missed I
think I get it out of this still keep
control over here and now the light
squares watch over this square right
here
is there anything tricky I'm not seeing
that the knight is boxed out by just
this pawn alone I have bishop check I
want to just pivot about on the light
squares and let me do what next move
quicker actually you know let's do this
actually I'm gonna reroute my pieces a
bit might be h5 okay I shouldn't have
done that I have a bunch of exchanges
maybe I should have allowed for that hmm
and have this as an exchange
oh there's still night there again but I
get my rook to F - okay this is working
out ff7 is difficult to defend an imam
is pawn actually ripped to f5 and I
think that's going to be it something
with h5 maybe h4 h5 is this leading to
mate something really close to it my
dark square bishop is going to be there
soon looking for mates I think this is
still just a one end game my opponent
has very little time let me just make
certain of some stuff I think they're in
a knot here hmm let me just make sure
what do we have Queen takes Queen and
then just box that out I'm gonna go for
that actually my King has a fast track
to what over here on the Queen side
right over here in this direction just
sneak up pawn push I could chase it away
with this Bishop and making inroads here
and now the next step is to box this
Knight back out and then take the knight
sneak in we're right here and then what
next I want to make sure that one of
these guys remains as a target okay I
could give a check and now come here and
this was not the best technique by the
way this final position definitely not
the best technique I mean it was winning
in that final position but there was
something more those are extra pawn rows
right there I should not have allowed on
those particular power moves there was a
much cleaner when I just wasn't able to
figure it out in time let me go back
let's see how there's a way for either
one of us to make improvement
let's see something was scaring me
around this moment right here when I had
to play the I don't know if I had to but
the Queen see one move I don't know is
there a way to capitalize on that this
is this was definitely running through
my mind here is there a way to oh I
think right here actually after this
exchange and I play my knight here maybe
just actually pushing and then after the
bishops come off planting this knight
right here
having to deal I guess with the knight
on this square but at the same time
maybe I have to be cautious of this
knight on e5 landing on d3 in fact there
might be something like upon an e4 the
Darkspear bishops are off the knight on
e5 and something like h5 trying to get
the light squared bishop Soph I think
I'd be needing to do h3 but I don't know
I thought that that was maybe an
interesting idea or at the very least
here's another one
in fact if after h5 threatening and
eventual Bishop g4 by the way if you're
not able to follow this this is um
you're really having to pitcher right
now the following the dark square Bishop
is off the board and this pawn on e4 and
this Knight now on e5 and what's going
to be important is this Square for white
to be watching out for because it's an
outpost and black will be having to
watch out for a piece getting here in
the meantime which could is probably
turning out to be quite disruptive but
um something tells me that this could be
still good for black maybe Bishop f5
trying to get the bishop maybe first to
g4 after h5 and if that if I am not
allowing the Bishop g4 move by playing
h3 I think Bishop f5 and then the bishop
is indirectly supporting a knight land
on this square so that's that's maybe
another direction black could be going
in from this point because I think I
stand better now because of this right
here connected past pawns and again take
into account what it is black is looking
to do blockade square this Queen this
rook this Bishop none of these guys
really like to have to blockade about a
passed pawn it's this Knight
who has the who acts as the best piece
for that role because it's not just
strictly defensive you'll know tonight
on d6 is actually putting pressure on my
old pawn the Queen definitely not Brooke
that's that's no good the bishop maybe
in some instances but it's the night
trying to get there so that's what
prompted my Bishop G form of getting on
this dog and I think has to be pretty
uncomfortable I don't know if maybe
trying beef live and b5 and c4 is a way
to go but anyhow I thought its I stood
better once we got into this structure
and we were just playing about with our
pieces so that those my main points
pretty much I think
I don't know I think yeah I think it
would have been pretty interesting if
we'd work with that different kind of a
pawn structure okay
good game and let's get another one in
here